[Music]
on this sunday night soldiers refusing
to relent
city steel is not falling defying
putin's surrender or die demand despite
his claims of control over mariopol the
belarusians backing ukraine the people
do not support him at all as their
leader continues to support russia we
hear from those fighting against the
condemned country the cost of china's
coveted control i think china realizes
that if it loses control it will have
hell to pay residents in a large scale
lockdown clash with police over forced
transfers to a corn team site
and migrants caught in a political feud
the texas governor sends busloads of
asylum seekers to d.c in a protest
against biden's border policies
[Music]
global national reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
russia's defense ministry says canadians
are among some 2500 fighters left
encircled in the besieged city of
mariopol after defying a surrender or
die demand earlier this morning the
number of canadians is not known with
some experts saying the number of
fighters still left is closer to 800
still it appears the shattered port city
is on the brink of falling which would
mark the kremlin's first victory in
nearly two months of war redmond shannon
has our top story tonight and a warning
some of the images are hard to watch
this is the huge azov style steel works
in mariopol according to russia's
ministry of defense it is the last part
of the city yet to fall
with troops holed up inside its maze of
buildings and tunnels
russia's ministry of defense says some
canadians and other foreigners are among
the fighters inside the factory
ukraine's foreign legion told global
news for security reasons it can't
confirm the presence of canadians at the
site the kremlin had given the soldiers
there a deadline of sunday morning to
surrender that has been ignored despite
a russian threat to kill anyone who
hasn't handed themselves over city still
is not falling
there is still our uh
military forces our soldiers so they
will fight till the end ukraine's prime
minister defiant when speaking on u.s
television sunday
for them life of the people did nothing
vladimir zielinski says peace talks will
end if the remaining marijuana fighters
are killed by russia the ukrainian
president told cnn why he thinks the
fight for the eastern donbass region is
so important
it doesn't mean if they are able to
capture donbass they won't come further
towards keith
that is why for us this battle is very
important for many reasons
despite russia's shift to the east and
south shelling continues in the north
too
the regional governor of harkeef says
five people were killed and at least 13
injured sunday with bombing reported
near the capital kiev too
a moment of togetherness and community
in the traumatized town of bucha a
service to mark christian orthodox palm
sunday worshipers praying for the dead
killed in alleged war crimes
this woman says her son sasha was killed
fighting russian troops
i don't know how to survive such a loss
she says
vladimir zielinski says up to 3 000
ukrainian troops have already been
killed and suggests the civilian total
is likely far higher than the official
un figure of almost 2 000 people redmond
shannon global news london
russia has increasingly become isolated
internationally but belarus which
borders both russia and ukraine has
remained steadfast in its support but
that position has sparked an anti-war
movement among its people acts of
resistance have sprung up within the
former soviet state and as jeff semple
reports a growing number of belarusians
are crossing the border to fight
in his first known trip outside of
moscow since invading ukraine vladimir
putin met with his closest ally the
president of belarus
alexander lukashenko blamed russia's
massacre of civilians in bucha on
british special forces and reiterated
belarus's support for putin's so-called
special operation
since the start of the war belarus has
allowed russia to launch attacks from
its territory but the position of the
belarusian president and the belarusian
people appear starkly different the
people do not support him at all
this belarusian software engineer is now
in ukraine fighting with the ukrainian
military part of an entire battalion of
belarusian volunteers one of their goals
to restore the reputation of their
people it was a big shame for
personally for me that
russian tanks invade ukraine from the
territory of my country for their
actions he and others would face long
prison sentences if they ever returned
home to belarus
that is as long as lukashenko remains in
power
position now is very fragile on that one
hand he doesn't have support of most of
uh belarusian people this belarusian
opposition leader lives in exile her
husband was arrested while trying to run
for president in 2020 so she took his
place and lost
sparking mass protests and allegations
of voter fraud
lukashenko clung to power with the
backing of putin but his support for
russia's botched invasion of ukraine may
have sealed his fate he
thought that he is on the side of
strong russia his future is under huge
question some experts believe
lukashenko's tenuous position is why
he's resisted russian pressure to become
directly involved by engaging in the
ground war directly
belarus can set and train dynamics that
can in fact lead to
popular unrest which could indeed lead
to the overthrow of the belarusian
regime itself and with russia's military
focused on ukraine an uprising in
belarus would be more difficult to quash
spurring speculation if putin loses in
ukraine his ally lukashenko europe's
last soviet-era dictator could be next
jeff semple global news toronto
pope francis made an anguished plea for
peace in ukraine today at his first
outdoor eastern mass since the beginning
of the pandemic
the pontiff called for an end to what he
called the cruel and senseless war in
ukraine delivering the message to an
estimated crowd of a hundred thousand
people in his address the pope also
mentioned canada's journey to
reconciliation calling for wounds to
heal as indigenous peoples continue to
seek truth this comes just weeks after
he met with first nations inuit and
metis delegates in vatican city
at least 17 palestinians have been
injured in a second round of violent
clashes with israeli police at the
al-aqsa mosque compound in jerusalem
israeli police entered the mosque one of
islam's holiest sites clearing
protesters barricaded inside tensions
are high as muslims and jews celebrate
ramadan and passover at the same time
palestinians have long feared israel
plans to take over the mosque compound
or partition it
one of the world's largest cities has
been shut down for weeks under china's
zero coveted policy shanghai's lockdown
is pushing the bustling financial hub to
a breaking point restricting its
residents from basic necessities and
causing more delays in the global supply
chain as mike drollet reports the rules
are revealing rifts over china's strict
coveted mandates
this is the shanghai china wants the
world to see empty streets and orderly
covet testing lines millions of people
united with the goal of completely
eradicating covid
videos like this paint a different
picture of residents being forcefully
removed from their homes to be taken to
overcrowded quarantine centers that look
nothing like the spacious highly
sanitized buildings presented to the
media
and when it was announced the buildings
in this area would be converted to
quarantine centers residents took to the
streets in a rare public protest that
was live streamed to the world
it is not unscathed in terms of moral
moral um you know vagueness but i think
it is doing the best it could given its
population density of a 26 million
person city the unspoken element this
epidemiologist says is that china knows
it has to tackle covet differently than
much of the world including countries
like canada because the inactivated
vaccines china chose to produce are far
less effective than mrna vaccines like
pfizer and moderna
that combined with low overall
vaccination rates could contribute to
the rapid spread of the highly
transmissible ba2 variant i think china
realizes that if it loses control it
will have um
hell to pay a domestically if if it lets
the virus spread so they're making like
a calculated decision
and uh obviously costing them
economically but you know in certain
ways they have the economic muscle to
tolerate and the political willpower to
tolerate it china is still trying to
achieve covet zero but it's also now
beginning to take a more targeted
approach while residents who test
positive for the virus are still being
sent to quarantine facilities officials
are slowly allowing some areas of
shanghai to open up while giving the
green light for priority businesses to
get the region's economic engine moving
again
mike trolight global news toronto
the number of migrants crossing over
from mexico into the u.s has hit a new
high the governor of texas is facing
backlash for his extreme measures to
control the influx now the state says it
is getting rid of migrants by busing
them all the way to washington d.c
jennifer johnson reports
four busloads of migrants arriving in
washington d.c
2700 kilometers from where they spent
weeks detained at the texas border
families now stuck in a political feud
as the republican governor of texas
takes aim at the white house over
greater numbers of immigrants crossing
into his state joe biden is not securing
the border the state of texas is having
to step up the migrants are arriving in
the nation's capital without support
tired and in some cases confused local
charities are trying to help
some had been traveling literally for
months some were fleeing violence
really desperate situations the white
house says texas is grandstanding to
bring national attention to greg
abbott's conservative views it's nice
the state of texas is helping them get
to their final destination as they await
in their their outcome of their
immigration proceedings the white house
was already feuding with abbott over a
controversial order the governor just
repealed requiring enhanced screenings
of truckers coming into the u.s from
mexico abbott ordered texas state police
to search the trucks for smuggled
migrants and narcotics pcst the mayor of
chihuahua mexico says the delays have
caused millions of losses in perishable
goods texas has backed off for now on
the truck inspections but abbott says
his government will still expel as many
migrants as possible we will increase
our border security in light of the
president biden's decision
to eliminate title 42 expulsions title
42 passed under president donald trump a
political ally of abbots allowed the u.s
to bar over a hundred thousand migrants
from crossing the border to stop the
spread of covet 19. the order ends next
month the cdc scientists determined for
on title 42
that it was an appropriate time from a
public health point of view to lift the
title 42 restriction with that gone
abbott and other republicans warn
another massive surge of migrants will
soon be coming and abbott is promising
they'll continue to be sent to the
nation's capital for the biden
administration to deal with
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up why canada's cannabis
suppliers are still struggling four
years after legalization
legal cannabis is big business in canada
contributing tens of billions of dollars
to the gdp since being legalized in 2018
but while the industry is a major
economic driver growers are still facing
challenges going head-to-head against
the illicit market matagahi takes us
behind the scenes at one of the world's
largest greenhouses
harvesting every week this is what a
giant room filled with almost a million
dollars looks like most of the value is
in this room right
this room has about 800 000 worth of
cost it is as sophisticated of an
operation as you can imagine pure sun
farms using 1.6 million square feet of
its property in delta to produce
mountains of legal cannabis inside a
factory of sorts professional growers
treating the plants like delicacies the
space smells exactly like what you think
it would it's also well ventilated
today we are the number one producer of
dried flower cannabis in canada and is a
single site operator or one of the
largest operators in canada if not the
world statistics have been harder to
come across since the beginning of the
pandemic
but the legal production and sale of
cannabis contributed 2.4 billion dollars
to bc's gdp in 2019. that year 19
percent of people in bc reported to be
using cannabis and 6.5 percent of
canadians pulled by statscan said their
consumption had increased at the start
of covet 19.
more than three years since legalization
taxes and strict rules slowing down
production have not made for a
completely smooth road but the province
and the industry both agree the biggest
challenge continues to be the black
market facilities like this are highly
efficient and from a cost basis we can
out compete the illicit market so i
think that's the first and foremost just
as important is the quality of our
product in terms of transparency and
clean product there's been studies done
that show illicit product is full of
pesticides and illegal contaminants and
we don't have access to any of those
products to use so customers know
they're getting a clean true quality
product when they buy legal sources of
cannabis what's next for this industry
could be lobbying the province for
on-site sales and regulated public
consumption facilities sometime in the
near future emadikahi global news
i believe the time has come to
re-evaluate the charter of rights
coming up the calls for constitutional
change on a milestone anniversary for
canada's charter of rights and freedoms
it has been 40 years since canada's
charter of rights and freedoms was
enshrined in the constitution the queen
and former prime minister pierre trudeau
signed the proclamation on this day in
1982 but indigenous people and
racialized communities were given little
consideration back then and all these
years later some canadians say the
charter still falls short eric sorenson
reports
1982 a defining moment in canadian
history repatriating the constitution
from britain and enshrining the charter
of rights and freedoms and with it legal
protections for all canadians the
canadian charter rights
which for the first time
give all of us an identity rooted in the
constitution that no government can
destroy
in those forty years canadians have used
the charter to challenge legislation and
the supreme court has ruled on
everything from abortion rights to
religious freedoms to hate speech
senator mary lou mcfedran a lawyer
worked on protections for women in the
charter this is an essential part of our
country of this constitutional democracy
but mcfedran and other human rights
advocates in a virtual presentation said
the charter remains a work in progress
the charter of rights and freedoms is a
strong promise but it's an unfulfilled
promise indigenous canadians and
racialized communities were given little
consideration 40 years ago there were
groups of canadians today who did not
have a voice when these were put
together i believe the time has come to
re-evaluate the charter of rights today
charter rights are still being debated
[Music]
the rights of the freedom convoy to
assemble in ottawa became an angry
confrontation ended by the government's
emergency measures a recognition that
writes under the charter can be limited
and the rights of many quebecers to
where religious symbols have been
blocked by the province's secularism law
that's expected to be challenged before
the supreme court the existence of the
charter is no guarantee that the rights
of canadians are protected that to keep
these rights we need to stand up in
defense of them anytime they are
threatened but in spite of some
disenchantment with the charter canada's
constitution is among the most admired
in the world says this constitutional
expert the constitution of canada has
influenced the design of the south
african bill of rights the israeli basic
laws the new zealand bill of rights
canada has become a model for the
promise and possibilities of
constitutionalism in the democratic
world
senator mcfedran pointed to the invasion
of ukraine and the war crimes that are
occurring there to remind canadians how
precious our rights are and how
important it is to protect and fight for
those rights eric sorensen global news
toronto
next a sign of the times the story
behind vancouver's nuclear weapons-free
zone
north korea claims it has successfully
test-fired a new tactical guided weapon
still images published by the korean
central news agency show the launch of
one or more rockets no date or location
is given but the images appear to show
leader kim jong-un observing the test
experts believe it is a sign north korea
could soon resume its nuclear testing
the nuclear threat from the cold war era
has been over for decades but one sign
of the time still stands on canada's
west coast esquire barnes reports it's
the last remnant of the peace movement
that swept the city of vancouver nearly
40 years ago
at the corner of broadway and boundary
road in vancouver is this curious sign
it's been there for almost 40 years
there used to be more of these around
vancouver
it's very much a sign of the time it
came from the early 1980s when vancouver
was at the forefront of the peace
movement
and libby davies was very much a part of
it you know we always understood that it
was
it was somewhat of a symbolic gesture
but it was a really important
demonstration of the
of what people were feeling at the time
what they were feeling was fear of being
caught in the crossfire of a nuclear war
between the u.s and the soviet union and
of course it's cities that were the
target of nuclear weapons and it was
cities around the world that were
leading
a globalized peace movement vancouver's
peace movement was led by a group called
end the arms race which would stage
massive marches for peace
it became so
popular in main street we would have
cops wearing you know badges saying
peace we would have the mayor we would
have you know city councilors like
everybody wanted to be there
in 1989 libby and some other protesters
put the words on the sign into action by
swimming out to the uss independence
which had docked in vancouver
vancouver weapons free zone you have
nuclear bombs on board we ask you to
leave our harbor right now
and every time i came up for a breath i
could see the sailors above me
uh hurling insults um and you know it
was to make a point that that
we didn't mind the the uss independence
being in the poor but we just didn't
want the nuclear weapons concern over
nuclear weapons faded after the fall of
the soviet union and most of these signs
eventually came down
by the city's hand they were never they
were never vandalized they would never i
never remember anything where people
were like you know that stupid or that
silly it was sort of taken seriously
like this is who we are this is what we
want our city to be
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm nitu garcia tonight
your canada is the view from mount
seymour in north vancouver bc thanks for
watching have a great night
you